[Music]  you're excited for the first day of  school  going to bayside is going to change our  life  why is everybody so rich  i just hope we can make a safe space for  these new kids i get where you're coming  from i'm coming from the bathroom you  don't know me  hey buddy hiya you only know how bayside  works for kids like you hot kids  privileged kids kids  isn't that nice hit it  [Applause]  we can talk about old times all day but  i want to hear what's new  bayside has been chosen to host the  southern california school spirit  competition i did not see this coming  that was too good to be true  [Applause]  [Music]  this is the greatest day of my life  the winner takes home a tiny spirit  stick oh my god the fun's just getting  started  wow the stakes have never been higher  you